each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available all right so it's our pleasure
to have Al uh kuu speaking today so Al
is visiting us um so he here is a
visiting researcher uh he's an assistant
professor at kach University and he
works mostly on cloud computing and P2P
networks uh security and cryptography
and today he'll be speaking about uh
some of his recent
work thanks Sun thanks everyone for
coming uh so this talk has two main
parts in the first part I will talk
about one specific protocol in a little
bit detail and the second part will be
kind of an overview of our other work
let's say as long as no one is in a
hurry I am not in a hurry so please ask
me any questions that you want
okay okay so I will
talk about Fair exchange first so what
this Fair exchange we will Define it
what has been done on it previously and
then what did we do which is this
efficient and scalable barter protocol
and then our implementation results on
it then we will apply this Fair exchange
to a case study in a peer-to-peer fire
sharing system and then as I said in the
second part of my talk I will talk about
other case studies regarding
cryptographic protocols for different
let's say
cloud uh
systems okay so let's start with Fair
exchange what's fair Exchange in a fair
exchange we have Alice and Bob they each
have an item that they would like to
exchange so what does it mean that the
exchange is fair at the end of The
Exchange either Alis gets Bob's item and
Bob gets Alice's
item or none of them get anything okay
so that's
fairness now fairness is Trivial if we
have a trusted third party that we'll
call The Arbiter okay why because Alis
just can send their files to the Arbiter
and then the Arbiter will send the items
if he receives both of them he sends the
items otherwise he doesn't Okay so the
interesting scenario here is what's
called an optimistic Fair exchange that
was introduced by asokan and
Whitner now what's yes point in the
financial industry this arbit is called
an escro agent you ever done a mortgage
true we will be actually using escros
very good point we will get to that
point so what's optimistic Fair exchange
we have this Arbiter but it's contacted
only if something goes wrong let's say
Bob cheats only in that case we will
contact the aror okay so we will we are
optimistic in the sense that we first
start by assuming everything will go
okay if everything goes okay Arbiter is
not involved the protocol is very
efficient if something goes wrong
Arbiter will be in
mod okay and what we want if something
goes wrong is a guarantee that arbital
will resolve the issue in some finite
amount of time okay Ely resolution is
necessary okay so let's see what has
been done on this and what we are doing
so optimistic Fair exchange as I said by
introduced by asokan and wner mainly as
a contract signing protocol so the items
Ellis and Bob were exchanging are
signatures on some message some
contract they also provided a file
exchange mechanism so Alis and B are
exchanging files this file exchange
mechanism requires another third party
that we'll call the tracker okay this
tracker provides hashes of the files so
that we can verify the file we received
is indeed the correct file
okay and unfortunately in their case the
tracker must be involved in every
exchange this is one of the issues we'll
Sol so indeed as part of our group at
Brown including Melissa here so as part
of our previous work we considered a bu
protocol what does it mean for a
protocol to be a by protocol one of the
parties item is money the other part's
item is let's say some file so I am
buying a file by giving money
okay of course what does it mean we also
have a third third party called the bank
the bank needs to handle monetary
issues and the next one this one I'll be
talking about in detail this is what we
achieve bartering which is much more
efficient than the other ones and here
we will also use money but only as a
warranty so in the wor case our barter
protocol turns into a buy
protocol okay so before we talk about
buy or barter let's talk about
electronic cash because we said we are
using money here so in this scenario I
will talk a little specific to this
endorsed e-cash
construction
but you can think of it as a general EAS
scheme as well so we have Alis pop and
the bank so Alis can go to the bank
withdraw some let's say number of Bank
notes and then what she does is the
following so she takes one of these bank
knotes she rips a piece of this bank
note
okay now there's this ripped piece and
there's the remaining bank note think of
this ripping process as unique so only
Alice has the matching ripped piece to
combine it back to a full bank note
okay so what we will say is that this
remaining bank note we will call it the
unendorsed coin
okay she sends this to Bob and then this
the ripped piece we will call the
endorsement now Alice will perform a
fair exchange of the
endorsement together with the Bob's file
to buy it once Bob obtains both the
unendorsed coin and the endorsement he
can combine them back get a full bank
note and then go deposited to the
bank any questions here why do you need
the first step why don't you do the fair
exchange on the full Bank mode because
this way it will be much more
efficient so just very simplistically
think this way exchanging a much larger
item versus exchanging a much smaller
piece
the file is going
big true but I will get to that I will
also give efficiency numbers and so
on okay so now we are ready to see the
by protocol the previous let's say
existing work so this is Alis this is
Bob this is our uh Arbiter as usual the
Arbiter has an orange key the color
coding is important so he has an orange
key key what does it mean the Arbiter
knows the orange secret key Alis and Bob
know the orange public key okay so the
protocol goes as follows Bob picks a
black key of his choice encrypts his
file sends it to
Ellis then
Ellice she wants to buy this file she
prepares this unendorsed coin and the
endorsement encrypts the endorsement
using the Arbiters
orange
key attaches a contract to this the
contract basically specifies that Alice
is buying this file from Bob and giving
him this
coin now once Bob receives these he
sends his black key so Ellis can decrypt
and obtain the original file and Ellis
sends the endorsement so Bob can combine
this with the unendorsed coin and obtain
the coin okay the bank
note the problem in the scheme is that
this step with the
orange encryption is a very costly step
so if Ellis and Bob would like to
exchange let's say multiple would like
to buy multiple files for each
file they need to perform this costly
step so the problem here is
definitely there's a scalability and
efficiency problem of course it's also
not good in terms of the bank because we
are always buying stuff so all these
will be deposited there will be
withdrawals and so on so bank is a
central entity this is not good the
solution is bartering so no money
changes hands if everything goes well so
we will see how to do it fairly
efficiently and scalably this will save
the bank from more work and this will be
actually much better than done over
multiple
files so let's see our barter protocol
we again have Alis Bob and the Arbiter
the Arbiter as before has his orange key
now he also has a blue key okay there
are two separate keys of the Arbiter at
this point so Bob sorry
Alice will again prepare this unendorsed
coin and the endorsement and encrypt the
endorsement with the arbiter's orange
key as before and she let's say attaches
a signature to this
encryption and then Bob picks and again
a black key of his choice encrypts his
file sends it now this is a barter
remember two files are being exchanged
so Alis will also encrypt her file with
her choice of Green Key then she will
encrypt the green key with the arbiter's
blue key not orange blue this time okay
she attaches the contract specifying
these files are being exchanged and the
matching signature to make sure
this endorsement the encrypted
endorsement can be linked to this
exchange by the way if I whenever I say
signature that's not really true I will
show the underlying system but for now
we can think of it as the only purpose
being able to match this message with
this message okay that's the purpose it
serves any expectations of how the
protocol will proceed any
guesses the two cancel out forget about
the signatures remember our goal is to
exchange two F so what should we do to
exchange two
F what does Ellis need to obtain Bob's
F the black key the black key thank you
so Bob sends the black key now the
response of Lis Green Key green key
that's the whole protocol
okay if something goes wrong for example
Alis chooses not to send her Green Key
she has already obtained the black key
so Bob's file she already has it in this
case Bob will take the messages from
Alice to the Arbiter and the
Arbiter will we will see the details be
able to give him either the Green Key of
Ellis or the endorsement of Ellis's
Queen check that is the green key that
was under the blue key in that second
one yes we will see exactly so it will
be either the correct green key or the
correct endorsement but either that's
important because if if Bob manages to
get both he has an advantage here okay
so if Bob didn't send his black key
sorry
garbage where in the
green this green key is garbage
or then what will happen is actually Bob
will obtain Al's
ecoin
but let me get to the details in a few
slides I will get to the
details if some if Bob let's say doesn't
send his black key then Alice will
contact the Arbiter again presenting
this contract and then if Bob has given
his black key to the arbor she will
obtain it as I said I will tell you more
details about this resolution
now what's important about this protocol
so we still have this orange encryption
that was costly that's what we were
trying to get rid
of the beauty of this protocol is once
this costly step is done the remaining
very very efficient pieces of the
protocol can be repeated as many times
as needed to exchange as many files as
needed
so if we want to exchange multiple files
we do this costly step once remaining
steps are all
efficient okay now the
resolutions so remember this is our
protocol if Alice doesn't send her Green
Key what
happens
so in this version that I am describing
there's a timeout a global timeout
not necessarily Global let's say a
timeout that Ellis and Bob agreed
beforehand okay and Bob is restricted
that he must contact the Arbiter before
the
timeout so let's assume he goes there
before the time out he presents these
messages from the
Alis so the Arbiter as the first step
will get Bob's black key he will store
it okay
and then of course this black key must
satisfy this contract he also checks
that then he decrypts this blue
encryption obtains the Green Key of Alis
he gives that green key to B if this
green key works Bob is happy he goes
home if the green key doesn't work as
any was
suggesting then Bob can take this
encrypted file of Ellis together with
this this green key and this contract he
can prove that this green key doesn't
satisfy the
contract once he proves that the Arbiter
will now decrypt this orange
encryption and give Bob alysis coin
essentially so now this turned into a by
protocol Bob wasn't able to obtain
Alice's file but he was able to able to
obtain Alice's coin what if Ellis
encrypted garbage as her coin she won't
be able to as in a moment we will see
what's the underlying
crypto what if Bob doesn't send his key
so Ellis needs to contact the Arbiter in
the worst case she needs to wait until
after the
timeout let's say she goes after the
timeout she presents the contract
if Bob has contacted the Arbiter before
the timeout and has given his black key
the Arbiter will send this black key
Tois if Bob hasn't contacted the
Arbiter then there won't be any black
key so Alis won't be able to obtain it
but if Bob contacts the Arbiter later on
the arital will refuse to help him
anyway so now they both end up obtaining
nothing so the exchange is still
fair and since this resolution happens
in the worst case at the timeout we also
have Tim
resolution okay so what are these nice
looking figures these orange Boxes Etc
so let's review some basic cryptographic
Primitives that we will use
encryption we will use symmetric key
encryption we will en cryp a file f with
a key K to obtain a cipher text
C so what claims he received garbage but
actually receive the file can you still
get the
money here at this step yeah
Gar so or is that somehow in the
signature very good point normally I
leave this outside the scope of this
talk so we can I can show the details
later on but here Bob is supposed to
show that this green key that the
Arbiter
provided together with this Cipher text
does not match the contract so the
contract in reality contains the hash of
this Cipher text so he cannot claim to
use a different Cipher text here and the
hash of the plain text that this green
key is supposed to decrypt this
one so in the worst case in a very
inefficient manner you can think of it
as Bob sending the whole Cypher text
Arbiter decrypting the whole Cipher text
and comparing with the hash but there's
a much more efficient way we can do it
without pop sending to whole
file okay so back to encryption we can
encrypt a file with a key get a cipher
text decrypt it back with the same key
to get the same file signatures we can
sign a message with a secret signing key
obtain a signature we can verify a
signature on a message with a public
verification
key escrow so what's an escrow escrow is
simply put an encryption under the
arbiter's public key together with some
public label so we encrypt some value
under the AR public key and attach a
public label to
this such that essentially decryption is
not possible without the correct label
okay the label is public but you cannot
modify the
label what's a verifiable escrow it is
an escrow okay so it's an encryption of
some value under the Arbor's public key
together with the
label but it's verifiable in the sense
that we can verify the contents of the
escrow without decrypting with only
knowing the public of the Arbiter the
label and the relation we want to verify
so without decrypting we can verify that
the value here satisfies some relation
for example what
relation we can use this endorsed dcash
so remember endorsed dcache has an
unendorsed coin let's denote it with
coin Prime and the endorsement let's
denote it with and so we can verify if
the endorsement matches the unendorsed
coin without decrypting that's the
key so this was our protocol let's
replace each one of these with real
cryptographic Primitives so what's
this
the unendorsed the unendorsed coin so
coin Prime in our case now this blue
encryption is a
verifiable escrow okay so within the
verifiable escrow there is this
endorsement and I slightly cheated by
saying this is a signature it's indeed a
public key for a signature scheme Al let
just generate a new public key puts it
as the label of the verifiable
scw this one very simple Bob has his own
black key sorry of course before that
Bob needs to verify if this endorsement
matches this coin Prime if it is then he
continues picks his own key key of Bob
encrypts his own file obtains a cipher
text Alice will do the same pick her own
key encrypt her file obtain the cipher
TT
text now this blue one the orange one
was verifiable this one is a regular
escrow okay so the regular escr of
alysis key so this green key now what's
the label the label the contract
specifies hashes of these files and
Cipher texts and some time value to be
used for the
timeout then she also signs this escrow
such that the signature must verify
under this public key this is how we
link this verifiable escrow to this
escroll so Bob does two things he checks
the contract he checks if the hashes are
the same as what he knows and that the
time value is not extremely
different we can tolerate large timeouts
in the sense that if there's a network
failure let's say Bob didn't send a
message but within 5 minutes his network
is restored he can just go resolve so
the resolution can be done in 5 minutes
but if we want to tolerate larger issues
this timeout can be much
larger okay he also verifies that this
signature verifies under this public key
if so he sends his key Elis sends her
key more
questions yes about the coin um I'm not
familiar with underlying eash but so
once Bob has the coin and the
endorsement he can somehow claim it
claim the money that's behind this right
exactly so he can combine this
endorsement and this coin Prime the uned
coin to a full bank note remember and
use
it Alice
can sure she can this is one of the
major dilemas of East schemes so you
either have offline ecast schemes where
yes Ellis can let's say reuse this coin
multiple times but then she will
eventually be code and penalized or
online East schemes where each time a
coin is used the bank needs to be
involved which is
centralized yes I have two question
about e because you said verify e so but
it's not a very I go X for e and this e
the es so we don't verify the es grov
this is a regular es grov not verifiable
we verifi the signature on the
escr and how do you get the ash of
f these ones these SES good so remember
the tracker that we mentioned so the
tracker gives us these
hashes in the sense that the definition
of this exchange is at the end Alis will
receive a file that matches this hash
and Bob will receive a file that matches
this
hash when we use it in peer-to-peer fire
and sharing it will be even more
clear okay what about privacy I was
quickly skip the signature Keys
encryption keys are all random we can
generate it each time we want to use we
can generate a new one if you are using
ecash as the
payment ecash is anonymous resolutions
are Anonymous the Arbiter only needs to
know if you are playing the role of
Ellis or the role of Bob but doesn't
need to know who is Ellis who is
Bob we can even further apply Anonymous
communication techniques to enance let's
say privacy if you want we also have a
generalized
version we can use any form of
electronic payments this should say form
that can be efficiently verifiably
escrow so that's the whole purpose of
using endorsed ecash it provides
anonymity and efficient way of
verifiable
escrows but if we don't care about
anonymity we can just use electronic
checks verify let SC them
done we can use any verification
mechanism we are using hashes to verify
that the files we exchange are the
correct ones if you want to exchange
signatures then we can use let's say a
public
infrastructure so the contract needs to
contain the public
Keys
okay if you don't like timeouts I told
you that I claimed that the timeouts are
not a big problem but if you really
don't like them
we have a version without timeouts the
only difference is instead of this
single costly setup step we have two
setup messages so it's twice costly
setup but the rest is almost as
efficient we have implemented all these
I will
quickly go over but all these buy and
barter protocols verifiable encryption
and those DC Etc using
C++ we we have done some improvements
over existing protocols such as multiple
coin denominations that's useful if you
want to exchange multiple files at once
so we just in some sense concatenate
them exchange them as a single file but
now if there's a if it turns out to be a
buy version if I am sending you five
files the coin should be worth in some
sense5 doll let's say okay five
minutes we have other
improvements over the even the old by
protocol and so on this one Z kpdl I
believe Sarah has given a talk here
before
so with all these extensions
improvements what we have
achieved as our goal is we enabled
hopefully efficient use of Advanced
cryptographic Techniques for cloud
protocols I keep claiming efficient so
let's see how efficient this
is
so for barter we have this setup phase
and then this per file part so the setup
takes about less than a second and let's
say 45
kilobytes but once we do the
setup the rest is something like 20
milliseconds and 1
kilobyte the rest is extremely efficient
we can keep exchanging as many files as
we
want and if you compare it to the old by
protocol it's essentially the total of
these so you need to do this for each
file yes please I see a big asymmetry
between Al's cost and bulb's cost is
that because Alis is the one tearing the
bank note in two so
yes there is the electronic cache Cost
Plus verifiable encryption cost
verifying verifiable encryption is
faster than really encrypting
it okay we have this efficient and
scalable barter protocol what do we do
with it let's look at a case study as
peer-to-peer file sharing so some
background this is slightly old it's
probably around 40 % now but it doesn't
matter so about half of the whole
internet traffic is due to peer-to-peer
fire sharing probably almost the other
half is due to
YouTube Okay so this bit torrent is the
most popular peer-to-peer file sharing
protocol so we will take it as our case
study there are these
trackers so these
trackers serve two purposes in some
sense one is they keep a list of peers
so other people who are in the system
and these torrent files these torrent
files are the files that contain the
hashes so when I go to the tracker and
obtain this torent file now I know what
are the hashes so if I am downloading
something I can just hash it verify it
against the torrent file and this is how
I know it's the real
file by the way this Pirate Bay tracker
bant has many many trackers this one
largest tracker only that one has about
40 million active users active meaning
uploading or downloading at any given
time so right now there are 40 million
people using Pirate
Bay of course the way we will use it is
fully legal for
example some kennedyan public TV channel
broadcasts are aired some norian
filmmakers use it to distribute their
films so it's a Content distribution
system Linux distributions are using bit
torent so how bit tent works is we have
Alis this is our tracker Alis goes talks
to the tracker the tracker gives her
this tent file and a list of peers some
of these peers will be ceders though
they have the whole file some of these
will be leechers they have parts of the
file F now files are exchanged at a
block by block basis not the whole
file so Alis starts exchanging blocks
the moment she has some blocks she can
start also giving some of those to other
Lees currently liit turn uses an unfair
exchange system so if let's say Bob
wants to cheat he can get LSS file
without giving away his
file we can use the by protocol to
achieve fairness in bit
torent but this will be costly or we can
use this barter protocol to achieve
fairness where ecash is only used
remember as a warranty system only if
things go
bad and if we yes eash so you have a
bank right yes so how do you how does
that the
model so Bank there are multiple issues
here you are right first of all we can
easily think about the bank being there
even without P2P so because we are using
ecash or the alternative is you can just
say I don't want any cash value this is
a bank only for peer-to-peer exchanges
it doesn't have any monetary value it's
some kind of a credit both of them are
possible what I mean is soting you want
everything to be decentralized right or
as much as possible so but if you use
eash you need the central you know some
Central
yes
good so remember we have the tracker as
a centralized entity but why do we still
consider this peer-to-peer because the
tracker is contacted only once in a
while right when I am joining the system
I get a list of peers so the bank I can
withdraw multiple Bank notes at once so
I need to contact the bank only once in
a while and remember if we keep
bartering no money changes hands there
are no deposits nothing so still I don't
need to contact the bank
much so if we compare the previous most
efficient protocol which is the buy
versus our barter protocol you can
easily see that there's an O order of n
efficiency Improvement if there are n
blocks that are
exchanged the nice thing about our
protocol is when we are doing this setup
we don't need to know how many blocks we
will end up exchanging we don't need to
even know which block we want to
exchange next we do this setup and then
we can exchange whatever we
want so if we look at this bit torrent
case study there's an average file size
of about 2.8 GB containing roughly 2500
blocks downloaded from let's say about
40 piers
if Alis and Bob buy every block from
each
other for a 2.8 GB file they need to
spend extra 225 megabytes just for the
crypto and 42 minutes just for the
crypto so if we use some standard
download times this corresponds to
roughly half of the time for just
downloading the regular file so 2.8 GB
file I would download in about 1 and 1
half hours but just to do this fair by
protocol I need to spend another 42
minutes if we if Alis and Bob barter
every
block the total overhead for a 2.8 GB
file is only 1.8
mbes and only 40 seconds extra on top of
the 1 and a/2 hour you need to download
the
file so I claim that for the first time
now we can really use a fair protocol in
a high churn system such as bit
turn because we managed to obtain these
two orders of magnitude gains
essentially you can download the
implementation the cash lip uh is
already online we are adding more stuff
to cash liip currently not related to
this but hopefully we will release them
on our group's
website so any questions about this
first part before I switch to the others
so did you really integrate your code
and plug it plug it into V torent or
just like simulation results some
colleagues of us were
indeed using our code in
uh lip torrent
library but unfortunately these are not
their results these are our uh it's not
even simulation it's just measuring the
crypto
part okay is a $4,000
fee
so maybe we need to erase this part from
the
record if you
download some let's say movie
illegally then this
movie Whatever Association what was it
called MPAA yes they will sue you if
they catch you of course if they sue you
they will generally settle down for just
a 4,000
fee this is just to you know convince
people not to download by example in
some
sense if you use SP exchange protocol in
in this P2P exchange yes situation who
is the uh
arbitrator can so we need that extra
entity called The Arbiter
unfortunately it's a proven result that
you cannot perform a complete Fair
exchange without an Arbiter you can't do
it
efficiently well sometimes we we we use
very
strong TTP trust the third TTP in
practice I mean in practice we usually
uh trust some very large company who
organize all of these so
this can be very efficient much more
efficient than other these kind of
protocols so if we trust that so yes so
uh if we use this protocol we have to
have
some uh advantage or some in PR I mean
in practice theoretically it's much
better but in
practice many people prefer this
e one so so if we are worried about
efficient
see as I said if you just spent 1 and a
half hours for the whole file 40 seconds
I claim is neglectable let's say on top
of that if you want at the end I can
also show some performance numbers for
the Arbiter so will the Arbiter be a
bottleneck in some sense but let me
leave it to the end of the
talk
yes might have multiple pairs so we need
to set up for every one of them exactly
so remember this these numbers assumed
this file is downloaded on an average of
40ers so this includes 40 setup costs
essentially okay so let's go to the
other works so I view
Cloud as having let's say two main types
of
systems one type is we Outsource some
job to a more powerful entity for
example maybe I should have changed the
slide
to Microsoft products so we can
Outsource our computation
to let's say Azure storage again and
then we can even Outsource file
distribution things like rapid share
that's exactly Outsourcing file
distribution they have huge servers they
can handle much more than our own
computer's
capabilities what's the other type the
other option is to Outsource to multiple
entities for example say at home did
anyone use set at home or any other at
home
project so what are your
experiences it works it works good so we
can use Outsourcing that way
so what they do
is you they the entral server
essentially outsources jobs to our own
computers
okay VOA they switched from being peer
to-peer but it was a peer-to-peer
storage system so you can Outsource your
storage to other
peers or for example things like Napster
again we are Outsourcing the
distribution of our files to peers
so multiple entities of course the
problem in both scenarios is that there
are no service security guarantees
resources are not under our control the
setting is
untrusted we have already talked about
this scenario in the previous part of
this talk so in the next part I'll be
summarizing what we can do to Outsource
computation to regular users Outsourcing
storage and then in all these scenarios
we will be addressing these issues we
will provide security guarantees even in
an untrusted setting even though the
resources are not under our
control so let's look at current
generation cloud
computing what's Amazon mechanical
torque it's a crowdsourcing platform so
we are actually employing human
contractors they are untrusted of course
the interesting thing there is the
employer must be satisfied before paying
the money but what's the job what's the
meaning of satisfaction these are these
are not well
defined another option set at home in
set at home you earn these credits for
reputation let's say they have no
monetary value the idea is that they
Outsource the same job to two
contractors and they need to return the
same result for the result to be
accepted now is this secure enough is a
different issue but this is a
welldefined
job
okay unfortunately you can't take back
credits and there are no guarantees on
the correctness of the
results what we can do for the Next
Generation this is slightly old work
although we are working with on an
improved version currently we can use
Game Theory and mechanism design
techniques together with cryptography
such that a
bus can Outsource a job to multiple
contractors some of them are honest some
of them are rational some of them are
malicious by properly finding and
rewarding them finding the malicious
ones rewarding the honest ones we can
incentivize all the
contractors to act honestly
furthermore we can limit the Damage Done
by the malicious contractors we can
provide provable guarantees on what they
can or can't
do does this have to be with can be done
all with your words and different levels
of words I believe you definitely need
fins I don't have like an impossibility
result on that but the previous systems
without using fines all fail to provide
such guarantees but how can you find
someone in this city at home for
instance if you can take that credits
mhm so what we are in some sense
suggesting is there should be a
mechanism where they can take that
credit and when I said we are working on
this recently is for example we are
integrating this with some ecash and
escrow based mechanisms to be able to
guarantee payments of reward
and guarantee payments of fines yes I
don't think there anything about
malicious computation but the day before
computers there were big computation
bureaus that Outsource computation to
battalions of people and there must have
been mistakes and sloppiness and they
must have had procedures for dealing
with it and the trouble is all the oral
Doctrine for doing it is is dying as
people age out somebody should catch it
soon true although I still don't know I
mean I am I would really doubt that they
have provable results on the damage that
malicious guys can do so we have results
that even if you are fully malicious
let's say trying to make us accept
incorrect
results let's say you can only make us
accept 1% incorrect results things like
those so we have proven results and we
will be releasing an implementation of
this next
month
okay so this is computation let's switch
to storage let's look at the current
generation cloud
storage these are license agreements
saying that Amazon can corrupt delete
destroy our files Google do not warrant
any security and so on so this is all
bad what can we do in the Next
Generation so we have this client who
has some precious data to store at an
obviously untrusted
server so the client sends this data to
the server and later on can challenge
the server to obtain a proof that this
data is kept intact this work has been
done by atenia Al ju and kiski and so on
in terms of these PDP and P
techniques what we
did as part of actually my lunch talk
was to make these Dynamic where where
the client can keep updating her data
get proofs of updates can later
challenge it get aof and so
on and again I will claim efficiency
here remember this talk is efficient
cryptography for the Next Generation
secure
Cloud
so each time the client wants to let's
say commit an update so these are real
numbers from real CVS repositories
there will be an overhead of about 10
kilobytes and 1
milliseconds now all the previous Works
in this cloud storage setting they
consider this challenge proof protocol
but none of them say anything in the
case the proof fails if the proof
doesn't verify what should the client do
what we show is that the client and the
server should be able to contact the
judge who can rule based on the
cryptographic protocols uh proofs that
they
provide and again this should be
efficient so since there's no previous
work we compare it with a naive version
of achieving
this our overhead is less
than 100 bytes
and 2
milliseconds for each time we need to
update versus an iive one would be 25
kiloby and 1 second for each update so
if you consider this uh CVS repositories
that have used many many many comets
over time so the naive version would
require 610 megabytes and 7 hours of
update uh
overhead whereas in total we require
something like 2 megabytes and 51
seconds okay so now we talked about this
Arbiter trusting the Arbiter so it's a
central entity we need to trust him and
natural question is can we replace this
Arbiter with multiple
entities maybe some of them are trusted
but some of them are let's say untrusted
they are evil
so can we do
this there's a very easy answer yes we
can if you are willing to use let's say
generic secure multiart computation or
Byzantine agreement type of techniques
if you are willing to incur this
quadratic cost of communication and so
on so now we want to do it efficiently
remember can we do it without this
communication only using autonomous
entities to construct an
Arbiter now if we only use autonomous
entities unfortunately we show that this
is not
possible in the sense that existence of
even a single malicious
entity destroys the whole
fairness and this holds true even if we
are willing to trust some k out of n
Arbiters or we want to trust some
particular subset of these
Arbiters
we can overcome this impossibility
result if we are willing to assume a
synchronized clock and there's a
protocol by aan and
W achieving this what we show is that
essential their protocol is optimal in
the number of unest Arbiters
required even in this timeout
setting okay so this should be the last
one authentication so the current
generation how does it work again we
have our client and the server the
client registers by sending a username
and password of her choice the server
stores this in a database later on when
the client wants to log in she sends the
same username and
password the server checks it against
the
database verifies if it's there
done in the best case currently what you
will do is instead of just sending the H
uh password you will send the hash of
the password so the server will keep a
database of usernames and hashes of
passwords now what does it mean it means
a dictionary attack can recover the
password and even if you trust the
server even though I trust Microsoft to
store not to perform dictionary attack
on my password if a hacker hacks into
the server they can get my
password there was a
breach that stole 32 million passwords
about half of them were susceptible to
dictionary attacks and a fun fact the
top password was 1 2 3 4 5
six 300,000
people okay this is the current
generation what can we do in the Next
Generation so for the Next
Generation the client should register
her username with a verification
key this must
be this cannot be a deterministic
function of the password as in the hash
of the password this must be a
verification key let's say for a
signature scheme so the server stores it
when the client wants to log in now this
is a challenge response type of protocol
but we care about usability so if the
client client needs to keep her signing
key on her laptop then she can't sign in
from let's say her phone her desktop and
so on so instead what we do is we show
that we can store this signing key
encrypted in the cloud with a
password and we prove sorry we have
other extensions where instead of the
cloud the client can use let's say a
mobile phone a smartphone or not even a
smartphone just a regular mobile phone
will be perfectly okay we don't need
enhanced
capabilities and by this method what we
provably show is that a dictionary
attack is not possible and this is
provably
secure is there an assumption here that
if you do a a search through the
password space you won't be able to tell
whether or not
you've
there are very nice underlying
assumptions one is that so this signing
key may depend on the scheme but for
many schemes that are in Ed it's true
this signing key is some random value
now if you encrypt a random value with a
password there's no way to perform a
dictionary attack because you cannot
verify whether or not the password you
tried decrypts
correctly now the only way to verify
your password attack is to go talk to
this
server and try to
login so we are essentially forcing all
the password based attack to be online
attacks so offline dictionary attacks
are
impossible exactly unless unless this
server and the cloud or your cell phone
is colluding I mean the you can do
Secret sharing to make it harder though
I mean the ific Keys public no this is
stored at the server this is the server
this is the cloud so somewhere else some
other place I mean so the the the one
the person who knows your encrypted
signing key doesn't know your
verification key the person who knows
your verification key doesn't know your
encrypted signing key kind of
secret the ver verification is not
public secret public secret verification
key in the sense that only This Server
knows
it actually multiple servers can know it
but this identification protocol and
then so you just do an identification
protocol to log in and then this is like
very simple you sign the challenge
return the
signature right so
then so as long as as this server and
this Cloud doesn't join together against
you there's no problem if you are
worried that they will join together
even though let's say this is Microsoft
this is Google what you can do is split
this signing key into multiple shares
store one share in Google one share in
Amazon one in Facebook
Etc so you just need an encryption
scheme and then an identification
protocol or like a signal protocol or
something and that's
it that's not even a sigma protocol
simple
signature of course you can get a
signature from Sigma but yeah so you
just need a w then you just need
something that's basically zero
knowledge so that the server can't go in
person later and then you
equi the you don't need full zero
knowledge I mean in the sense that if I
give you my verification key you have
some knowledge about my signing key
that's not full zero knowledge but you
still can't sign on my behalf
right just need identification weaker
than Z know exactly but that's basically
what
you okay so this has been a long talk
thank you for bearing with me what we
have talked about was we started with
networking issues in the cloud this
peer-to-peer setting and and the
fairness issues there we talked about
implementation we have some work on
Energy Efficiency as well that I haven't
talked about we have talked about
computation Outsourcing computation
Outsourcing storage in a dynamic setting
Etc and then
arbitration what if the storage proof
fails trust issues how can we distribute
these Arbiters and so on and finally
authentication and usability
issues future work I will quickly skip
but you can guess so more on storage
Outsource storage we have a distributed
version that's published recently Cloud
computation as I said this is work in
progress we have another work under
submission about Outsourcing databases
to the
cloud more work on peer-to-peer systems
economics game theoretic modeling of
these and how do we use for example
these Fair Exchange protocols maybe in
multi party computation setting or what
else can we do in terms of this
usability one last note is about
usability here so we said you also have
a version of authentication where you
can use your mobile phone if you are
required to
enter a long string to your mobile phone
no one will use it so we have many
versions of these
protocols and we claim all of them are
easy to
use and we have versions where you can
for example get more privacy out of your
authentication process of course in
return for some
efficiency let me thank my
collaborators so some of these guys you
know okay Anna you know Tolga Sarah B
you know Roberto you probably Mera you
know
Melissa and these are my collaborators
from coach University I want to thank
them all and of course I want to thank
you
yes the offline
you the problem is seems like this when
you are given some signatures signatures
are public even though the verification
key is not public okay you are given the
signatures can we verify some secet key
is a correct one or not so maybe it's uh
I need to check but it's possible for
several signatures like s so it's
different problem that is given
signatures yes conditionally given the
secret key is random or not it's not
random information theoretically and
even in
computationally so some signatures can
satisfy but yes definitely we need a
signing key that is indistinguishable
from random essentially here and
furthermore in practice whenever you
want to deploy this and use it we are
assuming as is in the current case this
is all done over
SSL
so we are not modifying this structure
essentially what Microsoft can do is can
use it only for their single sign on
server and then at the end of this
process they can issue us a ticket where
I can use it to sign into other sites so
the servers don't need to change as long
as a few single sign on servers like
Microsoft passport let's say uh Google
accounts
Facebook if they change their scheme to
this and now suddenly all these single
sign on type of sites are provably
secure against dictionary
attacks to the bank thing and um so I
mean kind of one the obvious question is
so in PP right having think a central
bank just probably is kind of bur right
I mean it's going a problem you want to
be decentralized
mhm also if the bank has a lot of job to
do like if if we are buying that's
definitely need to trust this bank to
actually be honest and if 50 or if some
percentage of the traffic is enal anyway
but it's not clear that um you can find
such a such a person but so the obvious
question is okay well can you replace
that with with Bitcoin right like is
there some sort of is that an easy
replacement where you can just say good
question just let's forget about eash as
we think of it in terms of crypto type
things I mean you know the standard
eash um and place of
Bitcoin so I guess we need to look at
two issues one as far as I know Bitcoin
doesn't have a security proof
so I mean we may lose our provable
security here but you may say Okay I
want to I'm willing I want to trade of
it for efficiency now the second thing
is we want to check efficienc it's also
distribution but we still want to be
able to verifiably Escrow that so can we
efficiently verifiably escrow Bitcoin I
don't
know that may be an interesting thing to
look at so these verifiable escro things
are these like very structured type of
encryption schemes or so the reason I
talked about a particular ecash scheme
called endorsed
ecash is because this endorsed ecash
together with Comm sh verifiable
encryption they work extremely well so
normally how can you obtain verifiable
encryption you encrypt something and add
a zero knowledge proof to that so it's
like yes so it's discrete logarithm
based
actually thank
you